hey nina what's up hey tom can you give
me a quick rundown on boba fett so boba
fett is a fearsome intergalactic bounty
hunter who the government hires to
capture a trucker his boss their smart
speaker and chewbacca and out of all the
bounty hunters that they hire boba fett
is the only one who thinks to look for
them in the trash okay so basically it
sounds like boba fett is pretty good at
being a bounty hunter it does sound that
way anyway after that the army just
gives the trucker to boba and then he
sells him to a handsy slug six months
later boba gets bonked with a stick by
accident and he falls into a giant sand
butt and dies
[Music]
what anyway thanks for calling always a
pleasure i gotta get back to doing some
stuff tom wait that can't possibly be
right uh i'm pretty sure it happened in
1983. no i mean if he died in a butt
then how come there's a show starring
boba fett on disney plus right now oh
you wanted to know about the new boba
fett the one that climbed out of the
butt there's more than one boba fett
kinda
great so our story begins on a very wet
planet a guy named jango fett a fearsome
intergalactic bounty hunter is there so
jango fett is that phoba's dad kinda is
he hunting a space bounty or something
no then why is he there oh it's nothing
weird he's just he's selling his dna
what no you don't understand nina see
some peace loving space monks asked the
wet planet people to whip up an army of
emotionless killers so the wet planet
people cloned a ton of django fence
since he was so good i don't know
okay but what's important is that jango
fett was all of the clone's daddy but
being the father to an army of
brainwashed meat shields wasn't enough
for old jango he wanted a clone a clone
to call his very own a special little
clone of his own that he would have all
alone in his clone home
and he got one one and that's boba fett
yeah basically so django what taught
boba fett to be a bounty hunter kinda
so for a while young boba wrote shotgun
in django's cool ride it's called the
slave one unless it isn't why do you
name a ship that dude just loves slavery
unless he doesn't is there a slave too
wow what a stupid question of excuse me
uh is there a slave to
is there no except yes
those stories don't count unless they do
anyway django fights some good guys
because he works for some bad guys but
like what he does for the bad guys it's
not really super clear but it doesn't
matter because a peace loving space monk
named mace windu cuts his head off with
a laser sword and so we see a young boba
fett for the last time in live action
clutching his daddy's decapitated noggin
on the field of battle okay so now young
boba fett's motivation and life goals
are pretty much locked in right so he
just wants to get revenge against the
peace loving space monks for cutting off
his clone dad's head kinda but not
really but maybe sort of
oh jesus christ pretty soon after his
dad's workplace accident boba tries to
kill mace windu by using a super duper
space bomb and it almost works but
luckily for mace he winds up just
killing some guy instead wait you said
pretty soon isn't boba fett like a
literal child at this point i mean how
old could he possibly be you know he's
the normal age for attempted murder he's
six why do fans even like star wars we
don't
okay boba becomes a teenage bounty
hunter instead of going to school and
learning math and whatnot he tries to
blow up some more of those peace-loving
space monks you know the ones whose
stated agenda it is to kill anyone who
disagrees with them so pretty much your
standard star wars stuff pretty much
your standard star wars stuff he rides a
giant dinosaur he uses a big tuning fork
to shoot a pink sea monster that was
eating a yummy spaceship at christmas
it's it's star wars stuff okay i'm
hanging up after that boba fett takes
chewbacca to the drugstore so that you
can buy an antidote to a sleeping virus
that two guys caught from a magic
necklace that turns you invisible why is
this not working but it turns out it's
all an elaborate ruse oh my god
this is the bad place soon after the
bounty hunter's plan is found out and he
flies away leaving chewbacca to tell
those two guys that boba fett smells bad
tom are you okay
are you high high on star wars
had those markers from earlier yeah that
tracks now nina here's where things get
confusing [ __ ] you the stuff where he
tries to kill the piece loving space
monks and then he rides that cool
dinosaur and all of the other stuff
that's not actually in a movie none of
it actually happened